Übung 2 kleine
ausfahrschritte starten Sie in einem
hüftbreiten stand und stützen sie die
Hände seitlich am Rumpf ab machen sie
einen Ausfallschritt nach vorne und
achten Sie dabei auf ihre Beinachse das
Knie sollte dabei in Richtung der
Fußspitze zeigen beugen Sie das vordere
Knie und halten Sie diese Position für 5
Sekunden achten Sie dabei darauf dass
die Ferse des hinteren Fußes
Bodenkontakt hält das Becken gerade
bleibt und der Oberkörper aufrecht
ist danach lösen Sie die Spannung und
Strecken das Knie wieder wiederholen Sie
diese Übung 10 bis 15 Mal auf einer
Seite und wechseln Sie dann das
Bein